في اسبانيا اصحاب باقدم مطعم في التاريخ
يحضرون لحفل تاريخي يحيون به مرور 300 عام
فقط على افتتاحه
امين مساحه في ساحه عفوا
في العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد هو مسجل في
موسوعه جينيس كاقدم مطعم لا يزال نشيطا تم
تشييده في عام 1590 ولا يزال بطوابق
الاربعه كما كان مختص بشواء اللحوم
الخراف الرضيعه ولكن على الحطب اكثر ما
يشتهر به بحسب ما صنفته مجله الاقتصاديه
الامريكيه هو فرن بداخله لا ينطفئ ابدا
منذ ثلاثه قرون بل تبقى شعله متقده فيه
ليلا ليكون جاهزا للشواء والخبز كل صباح
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات